what makes for a healthy happy
relationship she's my partner and
supports me with every everything and
she just uplifts me and we make each
other so much better and she looks out
for me it's I've never felt such a
partnership before like it's I don't
know how did you guys meet so you met
writing a song with each other I I've
been playing music since I was 12 and
have ever once Teen Wolf ended I kind of
wanted to you know really take hold of
my music career and was on a label and
this producer used to work with her and
he's like let me invite this artist to
write a song with us and she came in and
I was like I'm in love with you
it hit you it hit me hard and and we
really took our time with everything and
did it perfectly and naturally and it's
it's just the greatest I'm so in love
it's awesome I'm so happy thank you I
truly truly am that's so cool it's so
cool